اخرى الى عمان ومعنى من هناك وكيل الامين
العام للشؤون الانسانيه السيد مارتن
جرافيث سيد مارتن جرافيت كنت تتحدث عن
سماح الحكومه السوريه بالدخول المساعدات
الامميه عبر معبرين لمده ثلاثه اشهر هل
هناك من محددات لنوعيه
المساعدات التي سمح بدخولها
الى المناطق مناطق الشمال
السوري بادخال الامم المتحده لها
انها مساعدات انسانيه
وليس هناك سر متعلق بطبيعه المساعداته
الانسانيه نحن نرسل المساعدات الى
شمال غربي سوريا لعدد من الاعوام والقرار
الامس من قبل الرئيس الاسد والذي اعلن عن
طريق مندوبه وتم التاكيد عليه في الاعلام
هو ان يضاف معبران اخران لكي نزيد حجم
المساعدات وذلك بسبب الحاجه المتزايده
بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه هل هناك
معابر اخرى تقول زياده معبرين اضافيين هل
تقصد المعبرين الذين تمت الموافقه عليهما
ام هناك معبراني اخرين لتصبح اربعه معابر
معبران موجودان الان باب الهواء
وكانت هناك اتفاقيه لاضافه المسجد الان
نحن يجب ان يكون لدينا ثلاث معابر لادخال
المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا في هذا
الوقت العصيب يعني نحن نتحدث عن معبر باب
الهواء ومعبر الراعي ومعبر السلامه
نعم هذا صحيح تماما طيب فيما يتعلق يعني
اشارت زميلتي سلمى عن نوعيه المساعدات
يعني تقول مساعدات انسانيه ولكن المطلوب
في الداخل السوري اضافه الى هذه المساعدات
الانسانيه والاغاثيه المطلوب معدات
لرفع الامراض مع العلم ان الساعات الذهبيه
كما يقال وهي الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه الاولى
قد مضت ولكن
يبقى المطلوب مساعدات ومعدات ثقيله من اجل
رفع الانقراض وانتشال الجثث هل هذه
المساعدات ستصل الى شمال غرب سوريا بهذه
النوعيه
اعملوا ذلك لانني اعتبروا هذا الامر ايضا
انساني
فهو له علاقه بانتشال جثث الناجين
واجساد
جثث الموتى واجساد الناجين وامر مهم جدا
في هذا الصدد القيام بذلك
ويعتبر جزءا من العمليه باكملها وامن لهذا
ان يتم